hi terry you're cloud developer advocate
and you're here to tell us about three
tier applications on cloudrun that's
right in my previous jobs i used to
build three-tier applications with
containers and virtual machines and now
that we can run containers serverlessly
and effortlessly on cloud run that's
become even easier can't wait to hear
more
[Music]
first off terry i have a confession to
make most of my cloud run applications
have been pretty simple two-tier affairs
that's fine if you're building a service
that's a layer on top of database just
like the rest api for your application
but if you're building a web application
that sends html and javascript to the
user it's helpful i think to separate
that from the api that the web app uses
that makes sense do you have an example
app we can look at
why yes i do i created the sample to do
web app that you can use as a starter
for your own applications go to
deploystack.dev and click on the to do
app
okay doing so now
there's a button here for getting
started in cloud shell uh should i click
that yes
that will clone the repo to your account
and open a command line on google cloud
something that we call open in cloud
shell got it
then you can run the install script um
and this is going to take a couple
minutes
okay i'm kicking off the script now
see you back here after we've refilled
our tea or coffee sounds good
all right we're back the installation
script finished and it gave me a url to
the deployed application
and here is the working to-do
application i can add to-do items and i
can mark them as done
now you said that you'd wanted to know
more about the three-tier architecture
oh yeah uh could you tell me and the
viewers uh how this application actually
works
sure first uh go back to the
architecture diagram i got it uh here it
is
okay so at the top we have the web
browsers running on computers or mobile
devices and they connect to the front
end which is a cloud run service
and that box says cloud run but it also
says nginx yes nginx is a web server
that is very good at serving static
content like html and javascript to
browsers
i could have written some code myself
that does that but why bother when there
is a battle tested open source package
that definitely does it better
right better go with the wisdom of the
crowd uh when i open at the cloudron
section of the cloud console i see two
services to do api and to do fe here uh
the second service is the front end yeah
that's right the the other one is the
middleware oh right uh middleware let's
go back to the architecture diagram uh
what happens in the box called
middleware
well that is a rest api that the web
browser calls to read and write to do
items i like go so i've written it in
that language but you could write it in
any language that can handle http
requests and then you can put it in a
container
right
i write most of my cloud run services in
python or node.js
okay tell me about this yellow box here
titled vpc
that's the virtual private cloud for
this project the mysql database and
redis cache should not be reachable from
the public internet
we protect them by putting them in a vpc
the middleware that i wrote and go sits
in between it can be reached from the
public internet and it can also connect
to the database and cache on the vpc
using a tool called serverless vpc
access which we also configure in this
project
that makes sense
i noticed that the database says cloud
sql
yes the application uses google's
managed mysql product called cloud sql i
could have set up a virtual machine and
installed mysql on it myself but it's
easier to let google do that for me all
right and when i go to cloud sql in the
console here uh yes i see a database
instance yep that's the one uh created
by my installation script
all right
back to the architecture diagram again
uh the redis cache is there to speed up
the middleware right the middleware will
check the cache first when it needs to
read to do items if the to do items are
found in the cache the middleware
doesn't have to do a slowed database
ring and then the user will get the data
faster to their browser
i notice that the box here says both
memory store and redis yeah i made a
similar call as with the mysql database
i could have set up a virtual machine
and installed redis on it but it's a lot
easier just to use the google managed
version of redis called memory store
also the vpc security is very easy to
set up for that
very good this application is a great
template to build new applications from
so let's say i want to build an expense
reporting application and i want to
start from this your application as a
template how would i update the code
well that's where the ci cd layer comes
in we use cloud build to build the
containers for the code
store them in artifact registry and then
deploy to cloudfront all that is set up
and ready to go you can easily just swap
out the code and replace this sample app
with your own just edit the code the
docker files accordingly
very good uh what does this secret
manager in the lower right hand corner
do
secret manager is another google managed
service for managing sensitive
information for your application things
like passwords or database connections
strings etc
it can act as sort of a encrypted
environment variable store but for your
whole project
additionally access to the secrets and
the encryption keys used to secure them
can be managed by a developer themselves
in this project cloud build can
interface with secret manager and inject
the secrets into the configuration of
your cloud run service populating
environment variables in your
application
great thanks for showing us this
application terry i can't wait to use it
as a template for my next web app
and thank you everyone for watching if
you have questions for terry or me about
this app please add them in the comments
also let us know in the comments if
there are other serverless topics you'd
like to hear about in future episodes
see you next time
[Music]